oh the kindest thing i've ever been told
oh the kindest thing anyone said to me
that's tough that's tough wow
[Music]
so um recently one of my patients
uh told me or thanked me for wearing my
scarf and being where i am
what the the climate when we're in i
think that was the sweetest things or
the kindest thing
that in my it made my day at the end of
the day
you know
[Music]
you always worry about what people think
[Music]
and then him telling me it just you know
it actually it meant a lot so i was i
was happy
my father told me um this isn't the only
time he's told me
but there's this one specific time in
12th grade where he looked me just deep
into the eyes and said ethan
i'm proud of the man that you are and i
love you and that was one of the kindest
things that i've ever been told
how did it make you feel loved worthy
um enough
well i work with special needs kids and
um one of the mothers one day told me
that as part of the family
because her child actually learned how
to say my name
is one of the five words that you can
say and i think that
hit home with a lot of chords that i
became part of the family so
it just felt like i don't know it felt
like the
world was better brighter after that so
oddly enough
when i told a friend of mine that my
second brother had just passed away
instead of saying oh well at least he's
not suffering and
all of that she just stopped and looked
at me in the face and said
[Music]
and that was it it just meant so much to
me
because she didn't try to candy coated
and
it was just true emotion of wow
that must really hurt so it was
beautiful
probably on my birthday last week when
my sister told me um
you're like a dad to me so that made me
feel like i was doing something right as
a brother
somebody once told me that i reminded
them of a lighthouse
i'm gonna just assume it didn't mean
because i was six feet tall but
um they were just saying like that i
exuded light
and that people were drawn to me just
because i exuded light and
so being somebody that believes in god i
really just took that as a really big
compliment because
i want to be able to be a light for
other people and shine that to the world
around me so
i thought that was really kind someone
once told me i was a tortilla to their
taco
[Music]
[Laughter]
well mexicans love tacos so if i'm the
tortilla to someone's taco
that's a pretty big deal
i love when people tell me that i have a
beautiful smile or just that their smile
makes their or my smile makes their day
um it makes me want to keep smiling and
it makes me feel really good
in senior year of high school um it's
kind of like the end
of a year of a lot of like club
leadership um and one person kind of
came up to me and was like
um i just want you to know that like
even though
usually we really look up to extroverts
and people who are really loud and like
charismatic i think that even though
your personality isn't like
boom shakalaka that i really appreciate
kind of the very gentle and like soft
way that you go about
leading things i think that for me that
was really validating just because
i think that like oftentimes like i felt
that extroversion was a standard that i
had to live up to as well
and so i think it was really kind for
this person to go out of their way
and mention that to me before we
graduated i can't really remember the
specific words but it was the moment i
came out to my mother
and it was like one of the moments where
i truly felt that
there was absolutely nothing i could be
doing wrong
and just with her words and with her
space made me feel
yeah like yeah i was just i didn't have
to be anything anyone
i could just be unapologetically and she
gave me that first like feeling of that
space
and yeah i think that's one of the
kindest things that anyone's ever done
for me
i'm proud of you you said it my mother
made me feel special big humongous
she's seen me uh come a long way from
where i've been in the past and
just seeing the many steps i've taken to
better myself
and whoever had a hand in raising me did
a wonderful job
how to make you feel amazing made me
very happy
why do you think you chose that from the
ones you were thinking of
probably with my mom right now oh that's
your mom yeah
the kindest thing i've been told is
people say that they can see
the connection and bond between me and
my son and a strong love for each other
[Music]
so a long time ago i was coaching
baseball
for roughly 10 years and and i remember
one season in particular
i had a father son come up to me and
boyd never played ball before
and we went from wearing the glove on
the on the wrong
hand all the way to an all-star baseball
player in the span of one season and it
was after that season the father had
come up to me
and in so many words i don't remember
the exact quote
in so many words he had said you know
you've really changed my son's life and
you've given him a lot of direction and
excitement and it just made me feel good
you know as a small
gesture towards that boy and his family
you know to give a kid a lot of purpose
you know and focus
so now he's got a full full ride he went
all the way with baseball he's got a
full ride scholarship to a really nice
school in uh
in nashville tennessee so he's doing
great i think that's
one of the kindest things that
somebody's told me before
so the kindest thing i've been ever been
told is thank you
a patient of mine came back a couple
months after having her baby and thanked
me for delivering the baby
she went out of her way to do it it was
i was having a bad day at work and it
really made my day
and she went out of a way to thank me my
job is really hard and i
sacrificed a lot to do what i do and a
lot of times it's a lot of stress and
not very many things and really the
thank yous are
are really what makes me get through my
day and really actually
makes my job worthwhile and what's the
kindest thing you've been told
that hannah is a serotonin fairy
and that's your daughter yes my 27 year
old special needs daughter yes
one time my friend told me that when he
makes new friends i'm his standard of
friendship
[Music]
that he's looks for people who make him
feel as good
it would probably be you have a good
heart it makes me feel like i'm doing
something right
the kindest thing that someone's ever
told me is that i am the perfect
combination of both my mom and my dad
so i met somebody that i'd worked with
many years ago
i was walking down the street and bumped
into them and they
saw me and they ran up to me and hugged
me and screamed and smiled and said oh
how are you how you doing it's really
good to see you
and you're amazing and you did something
that changed my life
and that was great was fantastic it made
me feel good but i couldn't actually
remember what it was i did
so um i'm glad that i was able to help
somebody but
slightly unhappy that i didn't remember
the issue or the event
it was a teacher
actually she was from canada and she
said that i
that i'm a very persistent person so
that stick on my mind and and everything
that i do is
is with that with that in mind i'm very
persistent
recently my mom told me to forgive
myself
[Music]
lately i've been really being hard on
myself for
mistakes i might have made when i didn't
know a better way
how did it make you feel when she first
told you that
like somebody saw me when someone has
said that
like of course i'd be upset about
something when they're validating my
feelings like
instead of talking me out of what
i'm feeling or trying to fix it like
they'd say like of course you're upset
about that of course you would be
like of course you should want that or
of course that would upset you
right just like letting me have my
feelings because i think so often people
are trying to fix your feelings and
trying to
make them go away like people don't want
you to be upset
and um so i love it when people let me
be upset
and they like and that they can just
accept me that way
that i have the most beautiful son ever
why do you think hell sticks out to you
because he's like a part of me you know
it's like a
it's like my second arm you know what
i'm saying i feel like i only got one
when i'm not around him
[Music]
i've been told that i'm very resilient
and that i can
get through a lot of things i didn't
have the best childhood but
i think i've overcome a lot of things
and whenever i get
down or fearful i always keep in mind
those people that have always helped me
and been there for me
my abusive father wasn't a great guy and
i think a lot of people
unfortunately go through those
childhoods and it kind of
puts a lot of fear and doubt into how
you are
and as a person you don't know
how reassured you are you don't have the
confidence that other
people have and just getting through
that and knowing that
you'll be okay and everything will be
okay is
a really great message to have when
you're younger i have a lot of hard days
i definitely battle with a lot of
depression but
if you use the right tools and you
really
fight for yourself and you fight for
happiness
you can definitely get through it if you
focus on something that really makes you
happy
focus hard it'll get you through it so i
like that
i have a best friend that i grew up with
my best friend in the whole world
and he went on to become a
commercial airline pilot and very
successful
in uh in the army i called him up to
congratulate him and the nicest thing
anyone said to me is what he said
which is he said it's all because of you
and i said well where did i work into
this
and you said you were an example to me
to get into sports and
to be competitive and it made me feel so
good
i had no idea that i had even had an
impact on him let alone
he looked at me as the tribute to his
success
and i memorized a poem to go along with
it
you want to hear it yes it's called
sermons we see it goes like this
i'd rather see a sermon than hear one
any day
i'd rather one should walk with me than
merely show the way
for the eyes of better people and more
willing than the year
fine counsel is confusing but examples
always clear
and the best of all creatures are those
who live their creed
for to see good put into action is what
everyone needs
i can soon learn to do it if you let me
see it done
i can watch your hands in action but
your tongue too fast may run
and the sermon you deliver may be very
wise and true
but i'd rather get my sermon by a
certain way you do
[Music]
well now that i recollect you know
i can't think of any i think uh
most people these days don't take time
out to say kind words to
each other i think we need to spend more
time saying kind things to each other
you know
and i think that's what's lacking in the
world today
there you go how do you think we can do
that how can we make it a point to do
that more often
uh we just got to make a mental note
just like i'm out here
running and exercising i can make a a
matter of fact before this is over i'm
going to say something kind to you
so that's that's where i want to start
i'm going to start right here
and i'm gonna say something kind to you
you know you're doing a wonderful job
with your videotaping and uh
you seem to bring out the best in people
with what you're doing i think you ought
to continue doing
hey guys thanks for watching another
episode if you haven't subscribed to my
channel yet
and you want to subscribe to my channel
please make sure to hit the subscribe
button and the little bell next to it so
you'll get notified every time
i put up a new episode and if you really
really like my episodes
and you have some friends that you think
might also like the episodes
it would mean a lot if you shared my
episodes with them
as well if you want i think that's
pretty much it
thank you guys again and i'll see you
next week